hello friends i am dr umar malik and
welcome to math simplified
i hope all of you are safe in this short
video i will be talking about
hemorrhoids
commonly known as piles which is a very
common
painful and irritating disorder some
sources say that around 60 to 70 percent
of people will experience hemorrhoids
at one point or another in their lives
and an estimated 1 in 20 americans have
symptomatic hemorrhoids
hemorrhoids affect people of all ages
genders
races and ethnicities and they also get
more common as you age
affecting more than half of people over
the age of 50.
so let's first try to understand what
actually
are these hemorrhoids
well our rectum and anus have a rich
supply of blood vessels
and sometimes due to certain reasons
which we will discuss further in this
video
these veins get swollen and enlarged
these fallen and large veins that form
inside
and outside the anus and rectum are
termed as hemorrhoids
they can be painful uncomfortable and
can even cause bleeding
hemorrhoids can happen inside or outside
the rectum
the type depends on where the swollen
veins develop
based on this information they can be
internal external
or prolapsed hemorrhoids in external
piles
the swollen veins form underneath the
skin around the anus
external hemorrhoids can be itchy and
painful occasionally they might bleed
sometimes they fill with blood and they
can clot also
although this is not dangerous but it
can result in a lot of pain
swelling and discomfort
internal hemorrhoids consist of swollen
veins
that form inside the rectum your rectum
is the part of the digestive system that
connects the colon or the large
intestine
to the anus internal hemorrhoids may
bleed
but they are usually not painful
both internal and external hemorrhoids
can prolapse
meaning they can stretch and bulge
outside the anus
you may feel a mass coming out of your
anus
and causing discomfort just as the
previous ones
these hemorrhoids may also bleed and
cause pain
so who are at a higher risk of
developing hemorrhoids
basically anyone can get symptomatic
hemorrhoids even teenagers
you may be at a higher risk if you are
overweight or obese
pregnancy is also a risk factor for
developing hemorrhoids
poor dietary choices like eating a low
fiber high carb diet can lead to chronic
constipation
which is a very common risk factor for
hemorrhoids
habits like lifting heavy objects
spending a lot of time sitting on the
toilet
and straining while having bowel
movements can also lead to development
of hemorrhoids
now let's talk about the signs and
symptoms of hemorrhoids
internal hemorrhoids rarely cause pain
and typically can't be felt
unless they prolapse many people with
internal hemorrhoids don't even know
they have them
because they don't have symptoms however
if you have symptomatic internal
hemorrhoids
you might see blood on the toilet paper
in the stools
or the toilet bowl these are signs of
rectal bleeding
in case of external hemorrhoids symptoms
may include
an itchy anil area hard lumps near the
anus that feels
sore or tender pain in the anal region
especially when you sit and rectal
bleeding
prolapse hemorrhoids can be painful you
may be able to feel them bulging outside
the anus
hemorrhoids can be uncomfortable and
painful but they don't tend to cause
serious problems
rarely people with hemorrhoids can
develop anemia
blood clots in the external hemorrhoids
infections in the hemorrhoids
and they can also develop skin tags in
the anal region
your doctor can diagnose hemorrhoids
based upon symptoms and a physical
examination
some simple tests can also be done like
digital rectal examination
in which your doctor inserts a gloved
lubricated finger into the rectum
to feel for swollen veins this helps in
diagnosing the location
and also testing the effectiveness of
the current treatment
anoscopy procedure can also be done in
which your doctor uses an anoscope
which is basically a lighted tube to
view the lining of the anus and the
rectum
sigmoidoscopy or colonoscopy are
advanced procedures in which your doctor
uses a sigmoidoscope or a colonoscope
which are basically lighted tubes with a
camera
that help to view the inside of the
lower part of colon and rectum
these tests may be uncomfortable but
they aren't painful
they typically take place in the
doctor's office or outpatient center
without anesthesia
you can also go home on the same day
they are important because these tests
help your doctor to rule out dangerous
problems mimicking hemorrhoids
like cancers and inflammatory bowel
diseases
hemorrhoids often go away on their own
without treatment
symptoms like pain and bleeding may last
one week or slightly longer
in the meantime you can take these
simple steps to ease symptoms and reduce
the pain
you can apply over the counter
medications containing lidocaine or
hydrocortisone to the affected area
which helps in decreasing the pain
drinking two to three liters of water
every day helps in keeping the stool
soft and prevents constipation similarly
increasing your fiber
intake is one of the most important
things you can do to treat hemorrhoids
eat more fruits vegetables and whole
grains
doing so softens the souls and increases
its bulk
you can also take a fiber supplement to
get 20 to 30 grams of fiber per day
to start try a psyllium husk fiber
supplement
if psyllium causes gas or bloating try a
supplement containing weed dextrin or
methyl cellulose
sits baths are very helpful for
decreasing the symptoms of hemorrhoids
in a sitz path you soak the inflamed
area in water
for about 10 to 15 minutes for 2-3 times
a day
if you have chronic constipation you can
also try some laxatives to soften the
stools
you can also take some over-the-counter
pain relievers like
acetaminophen aspirin or ibuprofen to
get relief from the pain associated with
hemorrhoids
don't sit too long or push too hard when
you pass tools
go to the toilet when the urge hits and
don't delay bowel movements
use toilet paper with lotion or
flushable wet wipes
to gently pat and clean your bottom
after passing stools
this will provide comfort to your anal
region and prevent any damage caused by
rubbing
you can also use some topical treatments
like over-the-counter hemorrhoid creams
or suppositories containing
hydrocortisone
also numbing agents like lignocaine gels
may help in managing the irritation
caused by hemorrhoids
you should consult your doctor if
symptoms get worse or interfere with
your daily life or sleep
also seek help if signs don't improve
after a week of at home treatments
if your issue still doesn't get resolved
or some complications develop
advanced procedures to treat hemorrhoids
can be done like
rubber band ligation electro coagulation
infrared coagulation or sclerotherapy
also last resource surgical treatments
include hemorrhoidectomy and hemorrhoid
stapling
so i hope this short video was helpful
and you gained
some knowledge regarding this condition
and how to manage it
you can also connect to us by joining
our instagram and facebook pages
links are in the description below thank
you so much for watching and see you in
the next video